[Music]
I have come to this building every day
and done my job three decades I've given
to this office but honestly sometimes it
scares me I don't know what we do here
have I done something wrong
someone walked in from the other side
the other side I didn't do that man hi
Howard Lee do you have any idea how
lucky you are no one gets to meet other
other
thirty years ago during the Cold War it
was an experiment
something went wrong they opened up a
passage when you go through this door
you come out the other side you're in
another world identical to ours
there was one reality and then it
duplicated who we share genetics
childhood I want to know how you became
so different a kill order came out from
my side targeting people on your side
handle is Baldwin's he's a contract
assessment your wife may be her next
target we're caught in the middle of
something whether we want to be or not
you should just build a wall and never
come back
[Music]
they hate your sight for what you've
done to ours you don't know these people
like I do better not tolerate mistakes
the last thing you want is me with
nothing left to say
you
you